the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is that it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
everybody uh watching out on YouTube and
listening in on our Arthur C Clarke
Center for human imagination podcast
called into the impossible and today
it's quite a treat to be joined by three
distinguished intellects on my right is
Matt Kaplan of the planetary Society
thank you for joining us happy to be
here and honored to be included in this
group of truly great intellects I'm not
sure I qualify but it's like a crossover
episode you know cartoons yes sometimes
of years past uh and to in front of me
is Dr James Benford who is a proud
Hometown hero a Alum of UC San Diego
graduate in the class of 1969 in the PHD
program thank you James for being here
glad to be here always good to come back
to Paradise yes it was quite lovely and
I should say James is the president
founder of microwave Sciences in
Lafayette California and to his right is
Professor Paul Davies a man who needs no
introduction but I'll give him one
anyway he's the founder founder director
of the Beyond Center at Arizona State
University which in part is sort of an
inspiration for what we wanted the Clark
Center to be a home for intellects and
and excursions and the intellectual
peripatetic landscape that we like to
Traverse and I want to thank you so much
for being here and joining us last night
in conversation about ET and we'll talk
a little bit about that with the amongst
the four of us and Paul thank you so
much for being here well it's a pleasure
to be here and the Beyond Center we call
it the center for cool stuff and we
specialize in the impossible yes that's
right so as Arthur C Clarke our namesag
said the only way to find out what is
possible is to go into the impossible a
little bit or in some cases a lot and
last night we talked about the
possibility you're perhaps lack thereof
here on campus in conversation between
the two of you about whether or not at
is is perhaps already here not that
ET will be detected but perhaps there
are ways to detect that ET is actually
already Among Us and and why one way or
another and I wondered if we could sort
of discuss you both have novel ideas as
to how life could arise here on our
interplanetary surface that we call home
or perhaps near to us and yet have
evaded detection but you both point to
ways that a humankind could make first
Contact could discover the uh origin of
another type of life form and you both
have novel ways that you've decided to
approach this problem I think maybe I'll
start with with Jim Jim what are some of
the
um more likely scenarios in your mind
that might pan out successfully to
discover the presence perhaps in the
past of an extraterrestrial civilization
uh I've proposed recently that we might
look uh near Earth at the moon or the
newly discovered group of coorbital
objects to see whether or not
extraterrestrial intelligence had in the
past including the distant past located
a probe to observe Earth and the
residual probes now inactive might be
found or even active probes today in a
sense then we would be looking at
Interstellar archeology
artifacts from the distant past
observing the ecosphere of Earth would
this not be similar to another creation
of our namesake or related to it in 2001
the monolith that the uh that is
discovered on the moon and the
concomitant discovery of of Gravity by
uh by primates on Earth is that not what
Sir Arthur C Clarke was perhaps
expressing and in that same in that same
thing yes and in the predecessor short
story called The Sentinel in which the
monolith was not buried it need not be
because we couldn't have seen it from
the telescopes from Earth you have to go
there but burying it made it detectable
only by magnetic field and therefore
you'd have to be very sophisticated and
have orbiters in order to find it uh
it's very much like that I'm talking
about extraterrestrial artifacts yes
interesting so Paul here as you know we
have the World Famous San Diego Zoo and
whenever I take my kids and and uh
they're they're reasonably well behaved
at least half of them are and as we go
there we are always careful to observe
the the regulation that you may not
pound on the on the cages of the apes or
the primates or whatever that you have
to keep a keep a low profile and and
might it be possible for aliens to
escape our knowledge uh if they treat us
as sort of like those same Zoo creatures
where they just don't interact with us
but they're here in some other form is
that is that not a reason that they
could be lurking amongst us almost one
of the difficulties about guessing the
motives of an extraterrestrial
civilization and so they could be
stupendously far in advance of their own
and indeed there's no particular reason
why they will be Flesh and Blood beings
this may it may well be here on Earth
that we hand over the heavy lifting
intellectual heavy lifting to Design
Systems people
use words like computers and robots but
they fail to capture what in a hundred
years or a thousand years is is going to
take place here on Earth that that these
will be Design Systems uh and the
motives of uh the nth generation of
Design Systems are utterly Beyond us and
so if we imagine some other civilization
out in the Galaxy uh perhaps taking an
interest in the service system and
interest in humanity uh what what will
they be trying to achieve will they want
to make themselves known to us on
observers without being known or will
they ignore us completely we we don't we
have no idea so my attitude to searching
for signs that we're not alone is to
search wherever we can using whatever
technology we can particularly if it's
cheap and so at the moment seti has been
dominated by the idea that ET will be
beaming messages at Earth and we should
sweep this guys with radio telescopes
hoping to stumble across that message
directed to humanity I don't think
that's terribly credible I think we need
to Simply search every database because
alien technology May manifest itself in
a way that we would not even think of
and by searching every available
database I mean I'll give you a a quirky
example one of the things that's being
done
at the moment it's free on the internet
is sequencing genomes like crazy so in
the cancer research Community or the
biological community generally this is
the technology of choices yes you find
some sort of weird micro you sequence it
and all of this stuff is out there so
why don't we just search the genomes of
all of these organisms viruses bacteria
anything else you can get your hands on
it's all there you can write algorithms
that can search through to see if
there's a message from ET concered in
them but why might that happen how might
that happen well we can edit and
engineer genomes with our own technology
to put messages in genomes Craig Venter
did just that he put his email address
and some some poetry and Feynman into
the Genome of a an engineered organism
so you can upload information into
bacteria with a viruses retroviruses is
it conceivable that um Advanced
civilization has done this maybe in the
Deep past and this message is somehow
preserved we don't know how it would
remain stable over a long period of time
but if they've solved that problem that
the truth might be inside us you
shouldn't be in here right so you're
you're widely credited with uh
popularizing an idea that perhaps uh
because of the exchange between the
planets in particular between Mars and
the Earth over a relatively short period
of geological history maybe tens of
millions of years perhaps microbial life
could be exchanged and I think you've
said in the past we might find Life on
Mars but it may have come from Earth or
conversely life could come from Mars to
the Earth and and to my right is of
course Matt Kaplan who's a member of an
organization who spent a lot of time uh
thinking about Mars and and it's pretty
interesting because you think back to
Percival level in the early part of the
1900s uh thinking that he saw canals on
Mars and uh and yet the popularity
amongst the public of exploring Mars for
example
um uh still is so enduring and can you
speak about why is Mars so important at
least among in the popular cognizance of
a place to look for life or is it that
you know we're looking for water and and
that might be a harbinger of potential
Life on Mars what is it about Mars
that's so captivating why do we keep
sending so many very sophisticated uh
missions to go tomorrow
I think it's largely well I mean the
interest goes back to ancient times but
I think Percival Lowell had a lot to do
with this because he really was part of
that move at the turn of the 20th
century and a little before getting
people to think Mars may be very much
like where we live and wouldn't it be
reasonable therefore and of course when
he thought he saw those Canali and that
the Martians were smart enough to bring
water from the poles to the equator or
was warmer
um you know that's when you first
started talking about Medi right the
messages we were gonna build gigantic
semaphores and tell the Martians hey
we're over here your neighbors
um I think that stuck with us I mean
just look at science fiction and a lot
of bad science fiction movies set on
Mars
um that uh pushed this
um and of course you know NASA has gone
from Fall of the water because we
followed it we found it we know it's
there quite a bit of it to let's now
really start the serious look for life I
can't I I'm
as my boss would say uh Bill Nye the
Science Guy our CEO that if we found
life on Mars it would change everything
even if we discovered as Paul said that
that life maybe were cousins uh right
for me the fundamental question is uh is
Life as we know it just a freak accident
that occurred some in some little corner
of the universe where it's or maybe it's
spread around a bit maybe to Mars maybe
slightly Beyond or is the transition
from non-life to life built into the the
fundamental nature of the University we
live in an intrinsically bio-friendly
Universe in which there's some sort of
Life principle or Progressive tendency
right at the level of the laws of
physics and chemistry now if there is
such a life principle we haven't found
it yet and if you talk to physicists and
chemists about this
teleology is the technical term that
there's a sort of goal-oriented March of
progress built into nature it's anathema
to them and yet the same people will say
oh the universe is teeming with life on
the assumption that this transition from
non-life to life is a very natural thing
I might say that this has occurred just
during my career in the 1960s I was
really gung-ho for seti and looking for
aliens and so on and I might as well
have professed an interest in looking
for fairies everybody thought it was
absurd that life was a bizarre freak it
was limited to Earth complete waste of
time and money to look for any life be
on Earth and now everyone says oh yes
the universe is teeming with life and
yet the fundamental science really
hasn't changed very much in my career
people of faith we still don't know how
non-life turns into life
so speaking of messaging into space you
know what are they one of the chief
concerns about messaging to space uh as
expressed by Stephen Hawking who who was
Paul Post pointed out in the past came
up with sort of a version of the Fermi
Paradox for famous case of if life is
teeming and abundant throughout the
Universe how come where are they yeah
that's his question and Hawking had sort
of a corollary not just in space but in
time you know where are all the time
travelers you know there should be
abundant ability for Time Travelers of
the distant future to transition and
make these Quantum leaps backwards in
time and yet we have to date although
there are some people I think are quite
Spacey and quite out of time that I know
personally on the faculty no they're not
they're not my colleagues here but
um but nevertheless Stephen Hawking also
warned against the broadcast of our
presence here perhaps by high-powered
microwave systems such as the kind that
you've pioneered and written about in
your books but do you have concerns
about this messaging Medi messaging
extraterrestrial intelligence in that it
might be you know an eat here kind of
sign for the planet well I'm a moderate
in these matters uh middle of the road
meaning I think we ought to have a deep
conversation about it through
International means but that that
opinion which I've held for a long time
has not caught a lot of interest we're
not talking about it widely but I think
if if since it is now possible for a
billionaire to build a beacon that's
visible across hundreds of light years
we
ought to be thinking about whether or
not we won't allow that to happen or and
ask him what kind of message he's going
to send and whether we in fact want to
be heard at all that's a conversation we
need to have and I would encourage your
universities to to Advocate such do you
feel like we're on the verge of becoming
you know at least uh you know junior
freshman level interplanetary species we
will actually send thanks to these
benevolent billionaires I don't know if
that if they are or not but but uh what
this capability as Jim just said to
broadcast but also to fund space
missions and as Elon Musk said he wants
to die on Mars and as Lord Martin Reese
told me when he was here he's worried
that Elon will die on impact on Mars but
but besides that are we on the verge of
becoming an interplanetary species
ourselves and perhaps using ourselves as
a messenger to outer space well if you
count our robotic emissaries as being
among us as truly representing us we
have been an inner planet interplanetary
species for decades we certainly are
becoming more so you know our
as we speak uh Congress is putting its
um uh uh I won't say best foot forward
but a foot forward into weather and how
we're going to get to Mars and put
humans there and whether that should
come before or complement what we're
doing at the Moon
um the the current Administration and
therefore NASA have a somewhat different
view that this part of this Artemis
program one way or another and I'm only
talking about the US of course I think
we will actually be a flesh and blood
multi-planetary species at some point if
only Mars maybe Mars in the moon because
really where else would you want to live
except maybe on some huge O'Neill space
station right that's uh that's
questionable too but but I think we're
headed in that direction especially if
somebody comes up with a way to make
money out there right and they're still
working on that right and so Paul you
gave some arguments as to why a
extraterrestrial civilization of
intelligent beings might not want to
send themselves or their emissaries here
for one thing you know the energy
requirements needed to get a massive
object here of a reasonable amount of
mass and then to decelerate that object
so that it can have a nice soft landing
and become a lurking beacon on on an
interplay on inter solar system object
as as James as professed what are some
of the arguments against as you
presented and as you present in the Erie
silence the book which in part our
conversation was based last night what
are some reasons to be pessimistic about
the existence of life elsewhere and
especially technological life not not
just intelligent life well I already
mentioned uh the Big Air balls it
surrounds the probability that non-life
will turn into life given a habitable
planet so it's plenty of real estate so
which life could pop up but what is that
pop-up factor
that we don't know but even if it gets
going uh we still of course don't know
how likely it is that a simple microbial
life will eventually turn into complex
intelligent life however we do know the
process it's called Darwin in evolution
we don't know the process they turned on
life into life so that's still the the
big one yeah did Darwin say something it
was be as foolish to look for the origin
of Life As for the origin of matter he
did and it's interesting that we
physicists have now Explain the origin
of matter but we we're still stumped
with the origin of life but even
supposing it gets going and you get some
of our civilization then the question is
how do they best explore their
environment and the idea of traveling uh
you know Flesh and Blood beings in big
metal objects hurtling through
Interstellar space
we've been misled by too much science
fiction I'm afraid that this just makes
no real sense because why would you
travel you travel only for expiration or
colonization now if you want to colonize
that's a different matter if you want to
explore or you you would send robotic
probes as light as micro miniaturized as
possible at the highest speeds possible
it's still a very slow process so if we
were to send out probes even to the
nearest star at 20 of the speed of light
you're still waiting like 20 years to
get that information back and so it's
it's really a very long term project
might under undermine the motivation of
uh even the most curious Society but
travel for colonization is a possibility
but there are formidable obstacles so
let's just imagine we might do it yeah
you know wouldn't it be great to send uh
say a thousand people or another right
right we can all think uh we all have
our favorite lists of who should go
uh but if we're talking into Stella now
uh then uh probably uh we would never
achieve without some sort of Science
Fiction technology like warp drives and
so on but were there any physics we know
would never achieve anything that would
get you there in less than that several
thousand years and that's okay if you
can uh hibernate the crew but the one
thing that really bothers me and this
has only emerged in the last 10 years or
so is it's not enough to send human
beings and sort of basic foodstuffs uh
potatoes for example uh you have to send
the entire microbiology so we've got
more cells in our bodies that are
bacteria and archaea then our own cells
so this is part of the uh the the
so-called microbiome this is the life
support system of human beings and every
other organism has similar uh
microbiomes and if you ask the question
well what is the smallest subset of
terrestrial ecology that you can isolate
and be self-sustaining we don't even
know how to go about answering that it's
no good getting halfway there and find
some vital microbes being left behind so
we don't understand enough about the Web
of Life at that micro level to know just
what it would take so when you get to
the other end you might find a wonderful
Planet which is habitable but you're
lacking some really critical stuff to
have a self-sustaining ecosystem at the
other end right another one of your
brilliant graduates Kim Stanley Robinson
in his book Aurora which upset a lot of
people he explored exactly Paul what
you're talking about and the
difficulties of getting a colony ship to
any place dealing with the microbiome
and even just dealing with elements that
would be dissipated you wouldn't be able
to you'd have to bring enough I'm trying
to think of what some of them were some
of the compounds that you would need
um uh it disappointed a lot of us who
would you know have always believed that
humans would spread across the Galaxy
but it it's a very thoughtful book yeah
well let me say I thought the Aurora uh
plot line and in fact the basis of it
was actually wrong uh well he he wanted
that answer and so he got it you know
you can write a story with any ending
you want but they were in fact there my
brother and I wrote an extensive
critique of that that appears you saw
that yes
we should mention oh yes New York review
of Science Fiction uh published that uh
and it uh it said basically there were a
lot of uh choices he deliberately made
that made it to difficult uh not because
he didn't Discover it being difficult he
wanted it to be impossible he's an
opponent of interstellar flight and I
wanted to mention that what Paul is
saying uh he uh wrote about extensively
in a very nice piece and if people want
to know more about it it appears in a
book that I edited called Starship
century and he has an extensive
discussion of those issues about how do
you export a biosphere
so I want to read from the Eerie silence
speaking of your brother this is Paul's
book from 2010 so it's the 10th
anniversary of this book which itself
was written on the 50th anniversary of
Frank Drake and the osmo project the
first real search for extraterrestrial
intelligence in West Virginia with an
enormous radio telescope as I said built
in the 60s and as you say you know it's
depressing on one hand how little we've
made despite the truly Beyond Moore's
Law increase in capability we saw some
of the experimental capability we have
today just in UC San Diego and
throughout the whole world radio
astronomy has become phenomenally
sensitive and yet we haven't seen it and
so the probability you say here Paul the
possibility that alien civilizations
might might look
long ago have created powerful radio
beacons and that humans have the means
to detect them has been studied in
detail by Greg and Jim Benford twin
physicists working in California Greg is
an astrophysicist and also an
award-winning science fiction writer
while Jim is an expert on high intensity
microwave beam technology the way that
Benford see it ancient civilizations
could have many reasons to build a
beacon for example it could be a
high-tech moment Monument to a of Pride
to what may be a glorious but now that
long vanished civilization
yes at Beacon is also a great way to
attract attention and seek and simply
make first Contact to anyone detecting
it would redouble their efforts at seti
and thus it could conceivably be an
artistic cultural or religious symbol or
even the cosmic equivalent of graffiti
it might be a cry for help or as with
the humble Lighthouse a warning do you
still stand by these words that were
quoted by Paul in in this book 10 years
after its publication oh yes there are
many possible motivations uh what I
would uh one you left out is it might be
religious message because a lot of human
history is like the history of Islam is
let's spread our religion and that's
what a lot of people use the airwaves
for already I think that the fact that
we haven't found any beacons is starting
to make that look less and less probable
and therefore we are approaching a time
when we can say that that's a
proposition which has been falsified but
we haven't looked that much because as
you pointed out you need to stare at a
fixed patch of sky for a long duration
because this thing is going to sweep the
plane of the Galaxy and that signal will
repeat and I don't think anybody has
really put in a big systematic effort
well recall though that the Breakthrough
listen program is spending 10 million
dollars a year doing exactly that and
they're going to do it for a decade at
the end of that I'm sure that Yuri
Milner who funded it would like to have
at least a partial answer
uh yes but we're not there yet I think
yeah we're six years into it yeah um of
course and that's frequently said and
you brought this up last night uh that
you know uh lack of evidence is not
evidence of absence or absence of
evidence not evidence of absence
um and yet it is a you know depressing
thing to think we're 60 years on from
Frank Drake he still thank goodness
alive and well in Northern California
his eponymous uh Drake Equation being
kind of the foundation Cornerstone of it
as Paul as you point down the book it's
really an expression of our ignorance
and how little we know about it I always
say if my undergraduates turned in an
equation that had no error bars
associated with it I'd flunked them but
um but thinking about looking for
nothing you know basically in all the
right places uh it's got to do something
to the field and and that's why I do you
spoke last night Paul very eloquently
about the pop possibility of a shadow
biosphere can you say a little bit more
about that we had a conversation
um on the occasion of Primo Levy's 100th
birthday what would have been his 100th
birthday uh a couple months ago in 2019
on his famous book the periodic table
and also the uh which also had its 150th
birthday last year and a lot of things
had their the Dust Buster had its 40th
anniversary last year very important to
those of us with kids uh and I want to
know
um you know we we had a conversation
with with a a chemist here who studies
this difference in polymerization and
handedness chirality biochirality you
mentioned something which you know is
very widely underappreciated I would say
can you say something about this this
kind of thing that could be hiding in
plain sight perhaps in our own bodies or
in our biosphere yes I think this is
really important I've as stressed
already that the big unknown factor in
the Drake equation is the probability
that non-life will turn into life given
a suitable planet we have no idea what
that is but if we now take the
optimistic view that most of my Astro by
biology colleagues choose to take which
is that life will pop up all over the
place given half a chance then uh it
means that that transition from non-life
to life is really very likely under
Earth-like conditions well no planet is
more earthquake than Earth itself so
shouldn't life have started many times
over right here on our home planet uh
well how do we know it didn't has
anybody traveled to look and the answer
is almost nobody has looked uh and we
could imagine that life may have started
hundreds of times on Earth is it uh
possible that more than one form of life
has survived to the present day now it
could be that Life as we know it simply
eliminated all the competition but we
know that even among Life as we know it
there are for example microbes called
archaea we know microbes called bacteria
and they've co-existed peacefully for a
very long period of time so uh might
they be coexisting with another
microbial form that is not just another
branch on the known tree of life but a
separate tree altogether a separate
Genesis and how might we tell and so
we've held meetings at Arizona State
University and the Beyond Center to try
and come up with a strategy where would
you look what would you look for it's
actually pretty hard and I can give you
one example where it would stand out and
this is you mentioned chirality Life as
we know it is based on left-handed amino
acids and right-handed sugars that is
that if you look at these molecules in a
mirror they are certainly Allowed by the
laws of physics and chemistry but we
don't find normal life using them but we
can imagine mirror life where life gets
going a second time and everything is
around the other way and these two life
forms wouldn't be in competition really
apart from resources they wouldn't be
eating each other because they'd be
indigestible to each other so we could
go look for Mirror life that's a long
shot obviously all these things are a
long shot but there's a whole lot of
other things we could look for and one
that is my favorite is that we know
there's an upper limit of temperature
for life that we know which is about 125
degrees Celsius you find organisms
living at those temperatures in deep
ocean volcanic volcanic vents
extremophiles yes we call them external
files they like particularly like these
extreme conditions but the temperature
is coming out of these vents go right up
to 300 degrees something like that now
so if we found that there was nothing
living from 125 to 150 and then we find
organisms are living 150 to 180 say then
we would zero in on those at the
internal biochemistry would be different
so it'll be more heat resistant and that
would stand out much harder would be if
there is a we call it a shadow biosphere
this uh hypothetical alien life that
will be all among us if it was
intermingled with ordinary life and like
the same conditions and then separating
the sheep from the goat so to speak
would be very hard you can't tell by
looking under a microscope but just
little bugs and you need to delve into
their biochemical units you need to know
what to look for did you have a comment
you want to make sure to Ask Paula
how much looking would one have to do in
order to begin to falsify that
proposition uh well
um to falsify it uh that's a that's a
difficult one is it to say that to say
that there are that we can be absolutely
sure that a hundred percent of uh
terrestrial microbes Our Life as We Know
It uh the truth is only a tiny tiny
fraction of terrestrial microbes can be
cultured and only a fraction of those
can be sequenced so we just scratch the
surface of this microbial realm we don't
know what all those little bugs are
they're in their countless trillions
they're all around us and then we have
the viruses as well we have got the
whole uh virus there
and uh and we really I know we're near
but because the techniques of
microbiology are customized the life
that we know
it it's not going to work without a
thing that won't cooperate and if you go
to a lab and there's uh
some Paul Student trying to get their
PHD
um working with some sort of
extremophile organism and they have an
organism that doesn't cooperate and
there's floods and tears and you know
how you're going to get your PhD and
what happens to these organisms don't
cooperate well they go down the sink and
they work with somebody else uh and uh
that that's the problem everything is
customized to life for you know we go
looking for a you'll find a you won't
find B confirmation bias I want to close
in with a few more questions uh for each
one of you so first Matt
um what if the falsification comes I
mean what to what extent would that
impact Society I almost feel that
there's an urge an urge to feel that
we're not alone and and sort of hinted
at in Paul's in Paul's book right the
Eerie silence that there's something uh
perplexing paradoxical and maybe
unsettling uh to the human psyche that
what if we are alone what would the
implications be if the hypothesis of
alien life or even not technological if
we somehow knew that we're it what would
that mean for Humanity seems like a
pretty big burden for us to carry if we
learn about that because then it says
the universe is ours and what do we
decide to do with it how do we
bring the supposed benefits of whatever
our species is achieved across at least
our piece of the Milky Way
um I think you're right I think that we
do want to believe that we're not alone
uh and and yes I hadn't thought of the
significance of the word Eerie in your
title Paul but you're right it would
feel strange nobody wants to be by all
by themselves at least very few of us
um who was it that said that if we learn
whether we learn the Galaxy is teaming
with life or whether we learn we are by
ourselves either way isn't that the most
significant thing we may ever learn I
think that was Arthur City Clark of
course yeah that's right imagine for a
moment that Columbus had landed in a new
world and found no one there
that would have been very eerie for them
because every land they knew was
occupied by humans right and in fact the
new world was too that's right if they
watched him Discover it
so Jim you've worked on the you know
interface between and with your brother
as well between hard science physical
science science fiction science
non-fiction uh what what do you think
impels or you know compels you so
vigorously to explore these really
different or are they different maybe I
shouldn't impose my own viewpoint on
things but you know as a non-fiction
writer purely a non-fiction writer I
might spend six months on a single line
or equation or result or data point in a
paper whereas in a work of fiction it's
a former Liberty what are the aspects of
these two different genres that appeal
to you are there commonalities and and
lastly can you can you teach someone to
be creative in this way that the human
imagination is so well adapted to but in
such disparate ways the technical the
fictional Etc is that a skill that can
be taught the fundamental thing that's
necessary to be successful in those
Realms is one common trait curiosity
got to be curious about the world and
and what you're curious about may not be
as important not nearly as important as
the fact that you are curious or because
you're truly curious you'll keep being
curious about more and more things and
that's what makes life Lively for people
like us right someone said you know
Einstein said that curiosity is more
important than knowledge but you know I
know I want my my uh my heart surgeon to
be more knowledgeable than curious you
know what is this red beating thing in
my chest but it's not easy to make
people curious
lots of people who are not curious and
and if a lot of people if we found that
we were alone would just say let's stay
home it's comfortable here that's right
I didn't catch it it's too expensive to
go out there so yeah yeah I can watch it
on TV I didn't catch a fish when I took
the glass of water down to the black
speech uh and Paul maybe we'll close
with you
um you've written uh 31 books last time
I counted yeah I understand right at the
second you're writing another book which
is really impressive um you know as
we're recording this podcast here on
number 32. uh to to you know what what
is your process like I've always been
perplexed because you you are so
phenomenally
um creative but you have this throughput
that spans and and goes literally from
the biological to the astrophysical from
the microphysical to the cosmological
um is this is something that you can
teach I mean you're a professor your day
job you know your day-to-day job as
being a professor can you teach this to
young people and and what do you think
of the future of all these different
fields that you're working in well it's
interesting you should ask about
teaching because uh the uh just being
co-teaching with my wife who's a former
BBC Radio science journalist uh
co-teaching of course on science
communication uh and um uh it I I when I
was a Youngster I had no idea whether I
I never thought about writing in fact I
barely scraped through English and I
school and the first piece of science
Exposition I had to do was my PhD thesis
and it was only after that that I
thought well actually I quite like
explaining all this stuff and I could
probably as we would say these days dumb
it down a lot and it started off from
there but nobody ever taught me how to
do it yeah and what I found and it's
interesting that the entire students
were female
and among these these young women
a couple of them really had What It
Takes they were writing sample essays
that could have been published right
away and some of them were totally
hopeless and so I don't think anything
we taught them apart from a few obvious
things uh you know try to come to a
conclusion and don't exceed the number
of words and so on I don't think it
really helped very much I think you've
either got it or you haven't
and I write about things I'm thinking
about anyway I'm very fortunate that the
Beyond Center has enormous scope and in
my life I I regard myself as really a
theoretical physicist that I that's the
only real research as far as I'm
concerned her identity astrobiology and
cancer research and uh
philosophy of science and so on so I'm
thinking about these things anyway so
for me to write a book if you said to uh
to me could I write a book on black
holes I could probably do it in a week
but if you give me something more
challenging like uh I don't know
condensed metaphysics or something I
know less about it would take much
longer and so uh you know I tend to
write what I'm write about what I'm
thinking about it doesn't take that long
and that's the actual writing part as
Blaze Pascal said if I had more time I
could have made it shorter uh I do want
to ask you because I don't have these
opportunities very often if there's a
hyper-intelligent uh species of alien
somewhere or God or something like that
uh what question one question would you
most like to know the answer to during
your lifetime um I I've spent a lot of
time thinking about whether the
fundamental laws of physics which is uh
you know this is the sort of uh Daily
Bread of physicists you the in the
textbooks you use them where where do
they come from could there have been
otherwise Einstein said that the thing
that really interested him was whether
uh I had a good law had a choice you
know and uh what he meant by that you
don't have to be religious but could the
world be otherwise and still have
inquiring beings like ourselves uh
within it and that's something I've
spent a lot of time thinking about
throughout my career I sort of got it
from Fred Hoyle actually right uh that
he was thinking about these things even
in the 50s and we don't know the answer
to that question it's very profound
because it transcends actual science
it's about why is the universe
comprehensible and why uh consumer
beings actually understand it and right
and could could that world have been
other otherwise fascinating very good
okay well that satisfies one of my
questions that would that would be the
one question I would ask what would Paul
Davies ask the old one uh Matt Kaplan of
the planetary Society James Benford
microwave sciences and Paul Davies
Beyond Center the Arizona State
University thank you all so much I want
to encourage everybody online to
subscribe to our YouTube channels and to
our podcast on Apple podcast or Stitcher
or wherever you get your podcast please
leave a review and a rating it really
helps us very much to attract and grow
the audience uh thank you so much Brian
Keating from the campus of UC San Diego
at the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination
the only thing we can be sure about
the visit it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
foreign
[Music]